so took a couple weeks to get here but
they finally arrived pretty safe and
sound what's going on guys my name is
David Tomich welcome back to the channel
today we're taking a look at a non
genuine version of the Apple earpods 2
direct from wish which is labeled as a
refurbished model but if I'm being
honest with you
I've taken these out of the packet that
they came in and straight away I can
tell that these are definitely
definitely not a refurbished model this
is a high quality copy or replica if you
want to call it I also have a set of
genuine Apple earpods as well so I can
do a pretty good thorough review of this
product to see how good this replica
refurbished model is so let's let's open
it up and get started straight away
before we even open it up we can tell by
just touching the surface that it's a
little bit cheap a little bit nasty all
the folds Oh super paper-thin and you
can actually see where the fold line is
on the box which on the Apple original
product it's a nice embossed little logo
here of the headphones with some Apple
branding around the side and metallic
silver and some genuine stickers down
the bottom this one has none of that so
definitely some poor replicas there
these are meant to be some high quality
fakes ríos I don't even know what you
want to call them anymore but straight
away from looking at the boxes
themselves even the box itself is a
little bit bigger actually
so replicating the box they didn't do
too well at all we open this bad boy up
we have some Wow
definitely not Apple packaging so let's
get rid of that that's rubbish but you
know what not not not too shabby like
these look like genuine Apple earpods
a little bit of a
broken sound to the at the bottom I
reckon it's part of this charging port
that's a little bit broken a little bit
cheap nasty got a nice little clique to
it the green light comes on straight
away which is a good thing
headphones look pretty genuine pretty
pretty good I mean no faults so far
let's take a look comparing it to the
Apple original so when you take that off
and don't drop it you get the Apple
little logos instruction manuals
warranties etc in there and you get your
air pods as well these I've had for a
little while so the packaging is gone
but it usually comes in a nice little
packaging sleeve it you just pull a tab
and it comes off definitely not whatever
that thing was
but yeah so open them up definitely has
a more premium feel to it straight away
the hinge is a little bit more weighted
and the plastic is a little bit heavier
so this case is definitely heavier even
though this is the non wireless charging
version and this is the wireless
charging version really rattling
wireless charging version you think this
one would be significantly heavier but
this one feels very light whereas this
one feels three premium so taking a look
at the headphones again they look very
similar there is no design by Apple in
California assembled by China on the
back of these little wireless charging
cases but I've got the right headphone
here in my hand from the original and
the right headphone from the replica or
refurbished straightaway the colors are
definitely different the Apple original
is more pristine white whereas this is a
little bit more of an off-white I don't
know if it's just the angle of light but
it definitely looked different from an
appearance point-of-view pretty good
actually
they look bang-on identical
from all sides the one thing that they
don't have is the very fine very faint
print on the bottom of the headphones
that just gives you some basic
instructions Apple a5 a 1 5 2 3 china
very small text very hard to read and
otherwise well when you shine the light
on them and reflect the light you can
see that there's two little firing
speakers in the original headphone and
there's only one in the replica so I'll
do some b-roll for you guys so you can
see all of this a little bit clearer
than me just you know fondling around
these things but otherwise down the
bottom you'll also notice that little
charging points the contact plates if
you want to call them a significantly
different the replica is more of a fat
chunky kind of looking thing whereas the
originals have a really nice finished
polished edge you can definitely tell
these are more of a premium product when
you look at the bottom whereas if you
have the originals these are definitely
the fakes but if you don't have the
originals and you take them away and you
pop them back in the case and don't
actually throw them away cuz you know
you wouldn't be able to tell that these
are a replica I believe I think they're
quite a genuinely well made besides the
little rattle product so not not bad at
all but I guess the main thing is when
you take one of these products from wish
that's I paid forty one dollars for this
and I know the original is there about
two hundred two hundred and something I
can't remember off the top my head
exactly how do they sound is $40 any
good or do you have to actually go out
and spend the full money to get the full
quality that's something I want to test
out now so let's pop these originals to
the side and the fakes to the side grab
my iPad and start let's start with the
originals so we get a good sense of
what the quality of sound should be like
so the original is a straightaway
connected no issues whatsoever close
them up 100% battery so we know we're
going to get a full quality of sound
full quality jump on YouTube with a
music video let's crank up the sound a
little bit this is about 75 percent
okay that sounds pretty good that sounds
very good very high-quality lacking a
little bit of bass but that's just a
normal complaint you get from the air
pods it's nothing to do with the fake if
they're real or if they're fake let's
take a look at the actual fake ones
so excellent they connect straight away
no problems whatsoever
connected 100% on both headphones so we
have the same power level quality to
compare bring it back up to about 75%
no bad so I'm going to be a hundred
percent honest with you I don't hear a
difference and that's concerning for $41
I don't hear a difference to the two
hundred and something dollars air pods I
don't know how to feel about that
actually I was kind of hoping that
there'd be a little bit rubbish I guess
so I could say don't go and buy $41
whish headphones but besides from the
really annoying rattle there's nothing
wrong with them I think they're a pretty
decent replica I think you should always
support original product and not buy
fake quality things unless Ryan less you
have to if you have the money to afford
the high-quality originals with the
warranty and the Apple care and the
support definitely worth that because
wishes customer service is appalling and
you can never get anything out of them
so yeah not not the worst things in the
world sad to say and that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this
slightly different video to what we
usually do on this channel if you did
make sure you drop a comment down below
let me know if you'd like to see more of
this sort of stuff I know there's a
couple of black versions of these that
are meant to be extremely good
potentially I could get them in see what
the difference is if you guys are
interested in anything like that let me
know in the comments down below and I'll
see what I can source for you but until
then as always I'll see you next Monday